the impact of the corona virus outbreak
is being felt all over the world even on
one of Indonesia's most remote
archipelagos in tunisians airlifted from
China's Hubei Province where the corona
virus outbreak began have been brought
here tuna tuna they're in quarantine at
the local military base gomorian ah da
we considered several places but we had
to consider the runway for the plane to
land and the facilities so in the end we
decided Natuna was the best place this
is the town closest to the quarantine
facility just a few kilometers away from
the military base decorations for Lunar
New Year are still up but the mood is
far from festive many here are angry
they weren't told about the quarantine
plan one second Appa we didn't know it
was happening
no one gave us any information all my
neighbors were confused the town is
quieter than usual that's because many
residents left when they heard the news
fearing for their own safety I left a
few days ago and then I came back
because I had to feed my chickens but
I'm still afraid of the virus the
evacuees are in quarantine here at
national for two weeks in total that's
the incubation period of the virus but
if any of them show symptoms of the
corona virus all of them will have their
quarantine extended the Indonesian
government says it needed to act quickly
and that meant there wasn't time to
inform the Islanders beforehand now
government employees are going
door-to-door telling residents there's
nothing to fear because the evacuees
won't leave the military base as the
initial panic calms down the local
Education Board revoked its decision to
suspend classes because of the
quarantine trying to restore some sense
of normalcy in the midst of a global
health crisis Jessica Washington
al-jazeera maternal